It really is the White House that was supposedly
going to be all about transparency and openness
and, uh, keeping the American people informed
and part of the communication about what they're
doing has now gone six months without holding
a traditional press briefing.
There's been a different press secretary.
Uh, there is a different press secretary in
place now than six months ago, but it has
been six full months and there is no sign
that the White House is going to resume these
press briefings.
And part of the problem is probably that the
current press secretary wouldn't be able to
handle press briefings.
Her name is Stephanie Grisham.
She replaced, of course, Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
When Sanders left and recently Stephanie Grisham
put out a statement answering questions about
why, why are there no press briefings and
this is genius in the sense that it is evil
disinformation genius.
They are indirectly referring to Twitter to
excuse not having press briefings.
Check this out and look at the language that's
used.
Quote, this is White House Press Secretary
Stephanie Grisham to ABC News.
President Trump communicates directly with
the American people more than any president
in history.
The fact that the White House press core can
no longer grand stand on TV is of no concern
to us.
She's essentially saying Trump speaks directly
to the American people.
She means Twitter, right?
And thus we don't even really need press briefings
where of course reporters get to ask, ask
questions and sometimes call lies out.
Instead Trump goes on Twitter where it is
one way communication with Trump blocking
detractors on Twitter, people he doesn't like
and no opportunity for serious follow ups
from actual journalists.
That is what they are using to defend, not
having a press briefing in six months despite
claiming both before and during the presidency
that they are the most open and transparent
administration in history, which of course
only an idiot or someone can go a consistently
and persistently misinformed would ever fall
for and what's happening is that Grisham really
can't handle what it is that would happen
during a press briefing.
Aside from not even doing the briefings.
She also has done barely any interviews.
I'm aware of only one that she did with that
right wing TV station ownership groups, Sinclair
broadcast group, and specifically the interviewer
was that right-wing commentator Eric Bolling.
I don't even get what she's doing to earn
her salary.
She's not talking to the press in press briefings.
She's barely doing interviews.
I don't even really understand the point.
And of course, part of the explanation that
the press briefings are merely something that
allowed the press corps, which they've characterized
as just liberal, which is of course not true,
that it's merely a venue for the press corps
to grandstand.
This is another authoritarian tendency.
It's part of the presses bad.
Letting the press asks questions is bad.
Instead we are going to do one way communication
which is reminiscent of the endless speeches
of the despotic dictators.
The world over ranging from, you know, we
don't have to mention the German guy but we
can just go more recently Castro would just
do one way communication, uh, the Chavez Maduro
duo [inaudible] loves one way communication
with no opportunity for challenging and pushing
back against what's being said.
This is a hallmark of those with authoritarian
tendencies and this is actually particularly
of concern because it actually might set a
new standard or a new expectation even for
future presidents.
There would be, I'm hoping future presidents
that don't have the anti media authoritarian
tendencies of Donald Trump that don't share
his disdain for the press.
But if we go, not six months but another year
and a half up until the next inauguration,
if Trump loses, that would be two years of
no press briefings or almost no press briefings.
It may start to seem like the norm even for
future presidents.
I hope that that's not the case, but that
is a concern.
The most transparent administration in history,
right?
All they do is lie and obfuscate and then
canceled a few opportunities that even exist
to ask questions about those lies and obfuscations
and they defend it with, well, Trump's tweeting,
he's communicating directly with the American
people, so it's all fine.
This is the authoritarian slide that we've
been talking about for years at this point.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and I hope you'll join me tonight, uh, on
twitch
for
a live stream, twitch.tv/ [inaudible]
David Pac,